i can't speak for anybody else but yeah
that's just not not the not the move
right now
a huge party at the hype house tuesday
night is stirring controversy
with several of our favorite influencers
now facing backlash
for their rsvp welcome to the high pass
here's what went down
on tuesday night it was tick tock star
larry's
22nd birthday i woke up and i was like a
part of the high pass
his celebration started at a restaurant
before moving to the hype house
which recently relocated to the
hollywood hills
dozens of famous faces were seen at the
party on social media
including james charles and tana mojo i
aged like a decade
mentally this year all the while
california has seen record numbers of
covid 19 cases
wearing face masks and practicing social
distancing
have been the standard practices to
follow amidst the coronavirus pandemic
so the day after larry's party
criticisms began to roll in at sight of
so many people
who were not taking these precautions so
i don't live there
but they're all my best friends
obviously
tyler oakley kicked off the backlash
taking to twitter to specifically call
out people seen at the party
two hours later larry replied to tyler's
tweet
writing it was a dumb thing to do and i
will
do better tick tock star peyton
moremeyer told et
about his decision not to attend the
party
i love that you said that you're not
into like the whole
partying thing that you're trying to
take what's going on right now super
seriously
there were i literally just saw an email
come through about a bunch of tick
talkers
getting together at the hype house and
having a massive party
do you have any feelings on that i mean
i was i was invited to it i was gonna go
or i was not i was not gonna go but i
was like invited to it um
but i'm just i mean me personally
just not not the move right now um
so yeah i can't speak for anybody else
but
yeah that's just not not the not the
move right now
[Music]